so in in many aspects of his metaphysics
anselm of canterbury is best described
as a christian platonist or if you
prefer a neoplatonus
and this might be argued to be an
inheritance from the massive augustinian
influence on intellectual culture and
western christianity or from even
broader currents of christian philosophy
incorporating influences of other church
fathers gregory is very influential on
him john cassian as well or
other christian philosophers like
boethius however we decide to view
anselm's thought in relation to its
contemporary milieu and to his
predecessors it's clear that he found
certain features of neoplatonic
metaphysics congenial enough to
incorporate within his own philosophy
among these is the conception of degrees
of being
which plays an important role at a
number of points in this work another
centrally important aspect of anselm's
work is his conception of justice which
he defines as rectitude or rightness of
will maintained for its own sake
justice is the broadest and most
archetectonic sense of moral goodness
and anselm's moral theory it's also not
merely a matter in moral theory but also
along with metaphysical implications
in involvements not least because it's a
fundamental state of the will and has to
do with the relation between the human
will the created order and god who is in
some sense justice itself
so the problem that i'm looking at in
this paper
uh has to do with the intersection
between these two features of anselm's
lot the degrees of being
and his conception of justice
in monologium chapter 31 ansel most
explicitly articulates a hierarchy of
creative being in which he distinguishes
four higher and lower gradations
so the question i'm asking here is
could there be a fifth degree of being
which would be justice or just being
this is admittedly not a problem anselm
explicitly endorsed
a position he endorsed nor did he
consider it as a problem in his written
works
but it is one that does naturally arise
when thinking through implications about
topics where his metaphysics and moral
theory intersect
so addressing it sheds additional light
and other insomnia and problems and
doctrines with which it's interconnected
they talk about that in the fourth part
it does possess a solution which remains
faithful to anselm's thought and texts
which is an encelamian yes and no
depending on how we regard the matter
you know he's often called the
scholastic doctor in part because he
he
introduces all these distinctions and
and this is one where he would be doing
that so the structure of what i'm doing
here is relatively straightforward the
first section just sets out a selection
of passages from the ensemble's text
those that i have given you there
that are relevant to the question the
second part consists in exegesis of
those passages constructing an
interpretation of ansem
in which this would correspond to a
fifth degree of being higher than the
other four
in the third part i examined the
passages that would go against that
interpretation and in the fourth and
final part
i argue for a qualified version of this
interpretation of justice as a degree of
being and then i draw some of its
implications
for rational human being
two matters need to be briefly noted
here before examining the passages first
i don't intend to provide an argument or
justification for anselm's neoplatonism
unfortunately i'm in a room where
probably everyone is you know
more or less okay with with you know
entertaining the notion that there might
be something to platonism or
neoplatonism
well the basic conception of degrees of
being is indeed rejected by a lot of
philosophical schools
which replace it with other basic
conceptions it is one that's
representative of
several different long-running
philosophical traditions and i intend to
work out anselm's views within those
perspectives
second in this perspective speaking of
things possessing more or less degrees
of being more or less being does not
always imply that one is putting a
higher and lower degrees
setting aside quantitative differences
within the same level order of being
it's also possible for there to be
qualitative differences that are not
usable quantity
for instance of the sort when we say
that one work of art is more beautiful
than another or that it is truer to its
subject than another or that my wife is
more just than i am
it does make some sense to speak of more
or less being
for such qualitative differences if my
wife is more just than i am which is
actually the case because she has less
to be compelled to do
what is just than i am
in some derivative sense
and some would say we can say she
possesses a greater degree of justice
than i do and in that sense she is more
than i
it's more befitting to speak of degrees
of being when differentiating how
qualitatively higher and lower greater
and lesser levels of being
for anselm these degrees fit into a
hierarchical structure perceptible to
the human mind which itself in its turn
fits into that order
at the apex of this hierarchy for for
him is the triune god who possesses or
rather is the absolutely highest degree
of being the sum and unity of every
divine attribute
so the first part i'm just looking at
some passages that are relevant to the
question
um these are all from the monologian or
from the
day concordia so sort of you know
bookends first work
last work
if someone directs their attention to
the natures of things he senses that
these are not contained in one sameness
of dignity
but that some of them are distinguished
by difference of degrees for a person
who doubts whether in its nature a horse
be better than a piece of wood
and a human more excellent than a horse
really you ought not to be called human
this is one of the things that hansel
says
the next one he says
if from some substance that lives and is
sentient and is rational that it is
rational is stripped away by thought
then that it is sentient and after this
that is something living and finally
that bare being that remains who does
not understand that this substance that
is so bit by bit destroyed
is entirely brought by degrees to less
and less being and in the end to
non-being
but these things that taken away one by
one reduce whatever essence or being you
choose to less and less being when the
same things are taken on an order they
bring it to greater and greater being
so there's no doubt that every essence
by the degree that it is
more similar to that essence which is
supremely and is supremely excellent is
more greatly and more excellently
every created nature the more that it is
seemed to approach the word takes its
place at that higher degree of essence
and dignity
here's the third set of passages he says
created beings are always in the word
not what they are in themselves
but what is in that very same word
itself the more
they are similar to the word the more
truly and excellently they exist
second one whatever is made whether it
lives or does not live or whatsoever way
it is in itself in the word is that very
life and truth
and the third one
every created substance is more true
in the word that is in the intelligence
of the creator than it is in itself
to the extent that the creative essence
exists more truly than the creator
and finally here's some passages from
the day concordia
the good that is justice truly is
something that the evil that is
injustice lacks all existence
for injustice is not a quality or an
action or some essence but is so far as
an absence of that justice which is owed
and it has not accepted the will where
justice ought to be
and he also says
when the willing is rightly then it is
good and just but when it is not rightly
by this alone that it is not rightly it
is evil and unjust
for to be rightly is something but to
not be rightly is not something
now just as when someone uses a sword or
the tongue or the power of speaking the
sword or the tongue or the power
are not one thing when their use is
right and another when its use is not
right
so the will which we use for willing
just like we use reason for reasoning is
not one thing whether to use rightly and
another thing when not rightly
the will is neither more nor less that
which it is essentially when it is just
than when it is not just
so the second part now
this this first passage
fault introduces the doctrine of degrees
of being
and notes a very important point about
it at a certain degree of being that is
rational being creatures become aware of
the degrees of being and they become
aware in a reflexive manner locating
themselves in other like beings at a
particular degree in a hierarchy
at least potentially realizing that
they're not the apex of it
in the second passage anselm details
this thought experiment for us
progressively reducing a rational being
down through greater and lesser
determinations of being to bear being
than to non-being then by adding these
determinations reconstitutes it in its
full what i call ontological dignity
clearly in hanson's perspective newton
in indeterminate beings hardly being at
all basically non-being and certain
determinations of being like these
levels of living sentient rational are
not mere predicates
of an otherwise already constituted
being
instead each one of them represents a
greater richness fullness and intensity
of being a deeper engagement with being
which at rational beings level involves
this reflex of self-awareness
this second passage also provides us a
norm for ordering degrees of being and
the things which possess varying degrees
of being the norm being that of
similitude to the divine word
and sun
we know that the divine substance is
whatever it is absolutely better
whatever is absolutely better than what
is not yet he says and that it does not
have properties participating in such
perfections but rather is each
perfection or divine attribute itself
as well as their perfect unity
among these attributes
or qualities determinations of being
corresponding to the four grades already
distinguished he says god is supreme
essence and when he says essence
essentia it means something different
than you know what we might
look at it in a domestic sense where you
know essence and existence are
distinguished or things like that anselm
uses essentia in a kind of sloppy
way
i probably shouldn't say sloppy but it
means being you know doesn't just mean
essence in that sense
god has
supreme essence or rather is supreme
essence supreme life
supreme reason
and he also knows some things in in some
incomprehensible ways so he's supreme
sentience as well anselm's list of
attributes include a number of others
among which are supreme justice supreme
wisdom and supreme truth so given all
that we've cited thus far it would not
be unreasonable to suppose that a being
that is more just or more wise or more
true is thereby more similar to god
thereby possesses a higher degree of
ontological dignity
several other inferences lend additional
weight to this
ansel maintains a just but not a just
but not wise person seems better than
one wise but not just so given this
priority perhaps if any divine attribute
a person participates in besides the
four we've already mentioned
ought to be construed as a higher degree
of being it should be justice
it might also be significant that
justice is the very attribute that
anselm uses to
illustrate god's unique and supreme way
of being the divine attributes
and if the things being more or less
true arguably reflects greater lesser
degrees of being but surely justice
which in its broad sense is mutually
defined by truth and rightness and its
narrower sense involves rightness or
truth and will
should likewise involve greater and
lesser degrees of being lastly in
anselm's numerous discussions of human
and angelic justice and injustice it
seems clear
that not only do justice and injustice
each admit of quantitative or
qualitative degree so that a person can
be said to be more or less just
but also that justice by its very nature
is either possessed or not possessed he
speaks of it in two to
complementary ways
if anything is a candidate for a higher
degree of being
would it not be the justice
a human being possesses which
anselm says not even god can take away
if that person wills properly but which
once lost by justice's very nature one
cannot recover by one's own power
so in this interpretation
for a human being the state of justice
is or involves a higher degree of being
than that of merely rational being
the latter in turn is higher than other
progressively lesser degrees of being so
ranging from lowest to highest human
being would potentially comprise first
mere being new to mesa
living being
sentient being
rational being and then just being
at each higher level
there is an advance a leap beyond the
lower level
the creature has more being it exists
and relates to the rest of created being
in a richer way
at the same time while the lower level
is transcended by the higher for created
beings the lower level is also required
as a basis
a radically transformed one
for the higher level for instance
without being alive one cannot be
sanctioned
more importantly justice requires
rationality an important difference
between just being in the other degrees
of being however is that justice can be
and is in many cases lost so in this
interpretation a just human being would
occupy a higher degree of being than an
unjust human being who presumably then
occupies mere rational beings degree of
being
the third set of passages
would seem to strengthen this
interpretation
in these passages the being or existence
of created things as they are in
themselves that is in the world we
experience
is contrasted against the being of those
things as they are
in the word in god
they come out lesser greatly lesser in
the comparison for us human beings
original sin its manifold effects and
injustice plays significant parts in
this disjunction between the more real
ways human beings are in god's mind
that is the ways in which god intends
them to be and the ways they are in the
less real less true less just but still
quite existent created order
so for a human being to become more just
or for a previously unjust human being
to become just
would be for that human being
to become more alike to what they truly
are in god's mind
and when a person is just they are in
themselves more like what they are in
god's mind
senses anselm says nothing should be
other than what it is in the supreme
truth the very act of becoming more just
thus more like what one is in the
supreme truth
thereby renders one still more intensely
just so again this would go to support
this notion of justice as being a higher
degree of being
now i noticed i brought in some some
pretty questionable
ideas that you know there's me existing
in god's mind over there and that me is
more real than the me who's talking to
you right now
there's some
some clarification that's probably
required of that
but here's the challenges to the
interpretation coming from the day
concordia
passages like those in section d
problematize this interpretation worse
even if one were succumbed to temptation
to maintain an attractive but
questionable interpretation by saying
well those are just from the day
concordia so they're not really that
characteristic there's so many similar
passages that crop up through ensemble's
corpus
one would be forced to concede that
these passages really do reflect central
and unavoidable ensembian doctrines so
what are these
and what problems do they raise for the
interpretation so far one doctrine
essential to understanding anselm's
views is this
justice is fundamentally a matter of the
rational creature's will
justice he says
is that very good by which angels and
men are good that is just and through
which the will itself is called good or
just
justice however primarily resides in it
is equality of the will and likewise
does injustice the privation of justice
a will is and is called just or unjust
depending on the presence or lack of
justice within it and derivatively
actions hearts human beings as a whole
and angels are said to be just or unjust
so after noting that
consider three problems for interpreting
justice as a degree of being stemming
from hansel's texts concerning the will
of justice and injustice
the first problem is that
since the just will is not more a will
than the unjust will it would seem that
justice does not make the will a
different being
possessed of more being a higher degree
of being it simply qualifies the will as
just as having the property of justice
rather than its contrary injustice
there are other passages where anselm
does speak as if not only the just will
but also the unjust will are something
raising a second problem if both justice
and injustice are something
and human beings can possess either one
it hardly seems that justice could be a
degree of being in the way that
rationality or sentience are where the
quality is constitutive of that very
being
third problem
arises from other passages which specify
that justice is something
but that injustice is nothing merely the
lack of justice in the rational being
if injustice really is nothing how can
its opposite be something so much that
it constitutes get a higher degree of
being
than rationality
so it should be evident that
as i've stated these these three
problems cannot all challenge the
interpretation together because they
seem incompatible with each other
it also should seem obvious to readers
familiar with anselm's metaphysics and
moral theory that isolated parts of
hansel's thought from each other so
the solution relies and recons
reconstructing the proper context for
these
the third problem on consideration turns
out to rest on a dialectic stop short
that presumes that all the opposites
will be of the same level or order of
being as each other if injustice is
nothing but the privation of justice
where it ought to be an irrational being
there is no reason off hand
why justice could not be something so
important valuable and powerful as to
represent the elevation of the human
being to intrinsically higher degree of
being
and some in fact signals a necessary
priority which justice possesses over
injustice if anything the gulf of
difference between nothing and something
would seem to argue for justice being a
degree of being or at least not rule it
out
but the the first and second raise more
substantive problems
a human being cannot exist as such
without possessing rationality or life
though of course the human being does
not destiny these qualities totally
because only god does for hansel a human
being can however exist
without justice or without injustice
albeit they cannot exist concretely
without having one of them
and considered solely in terms of the
will anselm makes this distinction the
will is instrumentum the will as the
instrument
it is true that justice does not add
anything to the will since the will
remains what it is essentially but
in the other senses
of will anselm distinguishes will as
usus or occasion or or the actual
exercise
and will is affects your inclination the
restoration presence or preservation of
justice does actually add something to
the will
and injustice actually does take
something away from the will one of the
two most basic
inclinations of the will is in fact what
he calls the will to justice which not
only is something but something
exceedingly good
injustice is precisely a lack the
absence or privation of will as
inclination for justice
the case for will as occasion or useless
is less straightforward and obvious and
an interesting time i pass over here to
look at the second problems challenge
namely that injustice and the will
strictly speaking a privation of what
should be there
is yet in some sense something unjust or
evil
he actually does concede common use
calls the affects and acts of the unjust
will which consider themselves are
something injustice but denies that
injustice itself has any essence or
being
still in numerous works anselm does
paint detailed pictures of the varied
forms
some of them quite complex and enduring
this privation assumes in the subject
matter of the unjust will
these are closely connected with the
other genre of evils in addition to and
ultimately products of injustice which
and sometimes detriment
in some cases themselves appreciations
in other cases positively some things
like an addiction for example you know
he doesn't use that term of course but
that would be a great example while
injustice considered strictly in itself
is nothing in its effects it's concrete
manifestations
even in the tenor of its lack of will it
does seem something possessed of some
degree of being so in that case both
injustice and justice the
justice and injustice the first entirely
the second in a sense do have have being
now here's how i sort of come to some
sort of solution for hands on
uh on this he says he asked the key
question again does justice in the will
therefore in the human being as a
totality
bring or entail a higher degree of being
so anselm's doctrine
as i've reconstructed it here seems to
rule out justice being interpreted as a
degree of being entirely analogous to
those placed below it by that
interpretation
it's worth recalling that each higher
degree both transcends and
transformationally incorporates the
lower degree and that for each of these
degrees of being the beings which
possess them cannot be what they what
they are lacking them at least in some
respects the human will and the human
being can
lack justice and yet remain what it is
essentially and while justice could be
said to transformationally incorporate
rational being it does not
except as divine justice transcend
rational
in fact it's more apt and appropriate to
say that in anselmian justice is
something arising
as an essential and normative
possibility for the rational being from
the rat from that being's rationality so
it's a perfectioning of rational being a
growth in its rationality and a
condition for its rationality's
effectiveness
in this sense justice is an augmentation
in being
of the rational human being the
deepening of the determinative
reflexivity and relationality
characteristic of and arising at that
degree of being
so in this limited sense
one could affirm that justice is a
higher degree of being so we have our
anselmian yes and no depending
before ending i would like to lay out
four considerations about the relations
between justice and rational being in
anselm's thought and i put a lot of the
argumentation and exegesis and footnotes
the first one is this
will and reason for ansem are
inextricably connected and rational
beings both are structured in a
teleological framework that justice
makes effective
and injustice stymies and distorts so
justice is what permits rational being
to be rational being more fully
the second consideration
is that as rational beings we are
inevitably but also by our free will and
in responsibility caught up with either
justice or its probation
and if justice is not an entire degree
of being there is such a gulf for answer
between justice and injustice that
injustice can generate for rational
beings not only inability to recover do
or keep justice but even to understand
it adequately as well as casting the
will and the reason of the rational
being into servitude
the third consideration is it has to do
with the reflexivity of rational being
which is deepened and expanded by
justice when it's present
making possible genuine freedom and
self-knowledge
and revealing and reinforcing the true
framework of justice and the will
this leads in turn to the fourth and
final consideration
justice's relationality necessarily
involving and promoting the rationals
being
participation
in the economy of divine justice and
wisdom
to regard justice as something primarily
in or possessed by a human being
or
a human will is ultimately a two-partial
view for anselm
he doesn't say this but this is sort of
an implication of his
discussions
justice in the will involves rational
recognition of and volitional
harmonization with something
transcending the human will
an order of divine justice that is
ultimately god himself
so the will to justice to preserve
rightness of will for its own sake is
preservation of something the rational
creature does possess
but participationally
by participating in a norm of justice
that also exceeds the boundaries of the
creature
so ultimately just as he says for truth
and the de veritate rather than justice
merely being in us we are and we find
ourselves in justice
thanks so now
a lot of uh
anselm is an unusual guy
you know
when it comes to some of the things he
believes in
yeah i well when i was reading your
paper last night and you changed it a
little bit from i guess the text that i
had yeah um
i wasn't sure and
watch it reading it again with you and i
think i may have the answer but
i was struck by the idea that if
justice is a
higher perfection of being or
if it belongs to a different order of
being and i'm not sure if i'm saying
this the right way
the question
seemed to arise in my own mind if a
person were
supremely just yeah as a human being
would they cease to be human
no they would be most fully human
i mean that would be christ for for
anselm
um
you know you talked about a hierarchy of
beings and i'm starting to try you and
god and so you know down to inner matter
and you know we have
we have
a place for the angels and we have a
place for men and animals and that kind
of thing but
if and i guess i was misinterpreting
what hansen was saying because
uh it seemed to me that he was saying
that there was just a higher order being
and i was thinking of
some of the old theology for instance
well i better not characterize it as
althea
uh some of the theology for instance
surrounding the sacraments in catholic
theology
that there is a character
uh imparted to the recipient of the
sacrament
such that the the individual is marked
and that character changes
the person and now i've heard colleagues
of mine speak for instance those who
were ordained priests
that they were ontologically changed
yeah
and my my answer to them then is well
did you cease to be a human being you
know and because if you're ontologically
changed
and that's what i was reading as cell to
be saying that a perfectly just person
is ontologically changed it's a lot it's
a higher ontological state
and you know then then i said well
what are they there well yeah what are
they are they maybe yeah i mean it's an
accidental oncological change but
substantially
well it's you
well
which one are you saying is the
accidental anthology the character of
the second the sacrament
well it's certainly is not the way some
of my colleagues you know were
interpreting it they did not make that
decision they don't cease being a human
being because of that oh no but like you
said each step transcends the next step
so you don't cease being a sentient
being you don't cease being irrational
being but now you are a just
does that make you a super being well
that's my question that's not you know
well i'll put it through this one what
about angelic beings who are also
they also have wills the good angels
yeah they're they of course the bad
angels they can't fall uh they can't
lose the justice which they possess we
we can when we have a state of justice
that's what i was wondering about that
higher state yeah we still have the
possibility of always losing it and it's
not sure we've ever gone anywhere except
yeah we only lose it through anselm says
through um
our own will
through preferring
some good other than keeping that very
justice in the will
and we don't we don't conceptualize it
we always you know
we always think of it instead of
i'm just going to do this that one thing
make this exception for myself that at
this time
um
but but you know yeah we we have the
possibility of losing it it doesn't
uh transform our being in such a way
that you know like some some people have
this you know once saved always saved i
can do anything sort of theology he
doesn't have anything like that we have
that one without catholics in the
ongoing process so like maybe if i got
through cooperative grace sanctifying
grace maybe i would be the point where i
wouldn't change
yeah what are the possibility of turning
away
no that's glory to a glory before you
can't turn away
you
things have changed they just haven't
changed in such a way as to like turn us
into
automatons of grace so to speak you know
we still have ontologically though
i mean we're in
if we have the state of justice that
anselm you know
as he conceives of it we can't also
still grow with them
and once we're in it he thinks
there's nothing keeping us actually from
from leaving it leaving it except for
our own
will which is screwed up you know
damaged
uh and and uh you know we may be placed
in in situations where
there's a lot of pressure brought to
bear on us but he thinks that one can
once there is justice in the will one
can always persevere he also thinks that
if you've lost that it's not that like
everything you do is gonna be totally
flawed and you can never do the right
thing because you can't keep from
sitting you can't keep from
committing more injustice you can in
like individual circumstances but you're
going to give in sooner or later
yeah well like i guess you know
as you got towards the end of your talk
then it seemed to me that my question
was losing some of its vigor
because you said um
all justice could be said to
transformationally incorporate rational
being it does not transcend rational
beings so yeah as i read that i
underlined it again i said maybe that's
the answer to my question that he would
not really propose that
the fully just person
transcends the rational human person
yeah and i'm pushing anselm beyond what
he actually says to to be
quite honest you know
a lot of the things that he's
that i've got is the anselmian thing in
here are not things that he said
directly there are sort of implications
of putting together
parts of his
idea
um
i think the strangest thing that he he
actually says that i mentioned in here
is this notion that there's a me
who is the true me
who exists in god
and the more that i become like that
the more just i am
the more real i am
he i mean he says being
in itself
with this kind of being
not the being of a copy or something
like that is still not as real as it is
that
undamaged or redeemed me
you know
well that gets me back then to my
original question it sounds like you're
you're drifting back there then you know
drifting back to
my original question or my
interpretation of handsome as i
understood you were
you know
well
are we talking about theosis here is
that is that what the question is are we
talking about theosis here the sort of
becoming god notion
nope
it is yeah
although although that also is guy it's
it's you know right
right that's standard it's not the sort
of
high [ __ ] view but the ideas in god
are
not really distinct because yeah
exactly and you know things are they're
constituent with the
things of the world
too
you know um
well yeah anselm is neoplatonist in that
in that
in that respect thoroughly you know
and you know it's not like you ever
he there's some things in him that are
clearly up like this this degrees of
being business this this in the you know
existing in the
whatever i call it in the godhead in god
and god
this doctrine of participation which is
hard to make sense out of because he
doesn't tell as much about it what is
what exists what is it to participate in
justice you know i'm still trying to
work that out it's in plato
yeah
well
but that's not much of an answer for a
handsome because you wouldn't have much
uh who's arguably neoplethonic
and this kind of platonism runs through
some of the church fathers who he had
like for instance john cassian
benedict recommends cassian
as somebody who the monk should read in
this case in that case it's less about
sort of metaphysics on a grand scale and
more about the metaphysics of the human
person so the monks of the desert for
example is casting at least depicts them
you use the tripartite soul motion
coming from plato they also incorporate
some things from the stoicism too
i don't know if they have the
dana antara del rum
but there's arguments from degrees of
being in there in cicero the monks did
have some cicero
you know
um and anselm read all sorts of
we don't
we don't know much
specifically by his references to what
he's read because he's one of the few
authors at the time that doesn't quote
sources
you know
catherine rogers actually says
that
i don't i don't fully agree with her on
this that we should just see
um anytime that we don't have an answer
in ansel we just go to augustine because
he thought augustine was on track so
therefore
um
you know if he didn't if he didn't bring
it up he didn't think it needed to be
added to him
but you know people like uh
uh
robert
say that that gregory
is
almost as important in influence as
augustine when it comes to the notion of
justice is his rectitude
like
i accept that
that argument he's a cagey guy you know
we have these
we have these writings that he he
decided to set down
because monks pestered him into writing
and then he wrote a few because he
thought they they really needed that
and then you know pressures of of work
kept him from getting too much else
written in terms of high theology and
never actually did
get to address
the
story he didn't get to address
his uh
treaties that he wanted to write on soul
and figured that nobody after him was
going to do a good enough job on him
so so a lot of this is
is quite
you know quite speculative
but you were talking about
injustice yeah and you're saying that
you're saying that in a way it exists
for anselm as
evil here the being that evil has
is
through
the corruption of what being that there
is which is what palestinian uses are
the language which is interesting than
augustine but but i wonder why you
thought that was any
problem
i don't think that is i don't think
that's a problem for his schema in
general but if we want to say that
there's like these levels or or rates or
degrees of being
then
if if injustice and justice both have
being
um well injustice doesn't have being
that's important right yeah
it doesn't but it does kind of in a way
but not in a real way
like a hole in the ground
yeah because the hole in the ground
exists or does it not yeah except like a
hole in the ground hole in the ground
filled with glass that shouldn't be
there you know that you step in
uh
that's a form of injustice
um
yeah exactly is that just
it's not just a lack of order though
it's also
a misorder
too to a certain degree
this is why i mean it's very difficult
to talk about
evil as merely privation
you know
or at least it is for for me yeah